[Música]
alguns anos atrás eu estava na ponte
aérea voltando do rio de janeiro e uma
semana particularmente difícil
era uma época que não me alimentava bem
não dormia lei eu vivi uma das épocas
mais difíceis da minha vida profissional
e quando entrei no avião e sentei fiz o
óbvio
abri o computador para trabalhar
agora a moça tem me pedido para fechar
disseram que o vôo estava lotado e que
não era permitido a verdade dizendo que
estava na saída de emergência que não
era permitido o uso de computadores
eu tentei mudar já cento obviamente mas
voltava lotado então como de costume já
estava pronta para colocar um fone de
ouvido
quando eu tenho a seguinte frase por que
você não aproveita esses 40 minutos pra
você
eles não vão mudar nada na sua vida
quando virei um homem simpático sorriu e
continuou dizendo sabe que eu já mandei
do brasil faz um tempo mas me assusta
cada vez que eu venho pra cá
dez pessoas trabalhando e vendo nesse
ritmo e ver que eu vivia exatamente
assim
eu fiquei envergonhada gente jogar o
assunto principal forte maratona
bicicleta mas logo ele me perguntou e
computador em que tem ele de tão
importante eu contei que trabalhava no
linkedin e ele me perguntou se eu
conhecia osvaldo quero anunciou na época
eu disse claro de onde você conhece ele
então ele me disse eu vim desse mercado
fui eu que trouxe o google e facebook no
brasil
gente que desesperada mil conexões
passaram na minha cabeça pessoas frases
notícias
eu sabia quem tinha trazido o google e
facebook do brasil esse cara é uma
referência pra mim mesmo super empolgada
aquele momento continua na surpresa agir
naturalmente que disse a você o harley e
ele disse sou o fato de não saber quem
era ele me deixa mais à vontade para ser
eu mesma
pelo menos até aquele momento né
a gente falou sobre diversos assuntos a
startup empreendedorismo projetos
sociais google facebook instagram podia
dizer que tinha ido pra europa mas já
cheguei no são paulo eu pensei o que eu
poderia perguntar pra esse cara que de
alguma forma poderia mudar a minha
carreira
então criei coragem disse o que você
olha antes de contratar alguém
entendendo que ele deveria ter
contratado um time muito bom para essas
empresas estariam elas estão hoje e ele
me disse que eu era basicamente cinco
coisas más que tinha uma chamava muita
atenção dele quer entender quem era
aquela pessoa fora do ambiente de
trabalho
ele contou então um caso de quando
contratou uma pessoa para o google para
financeira que era um palhaço fora do
escritório e disse que acho que eu tinha
chamado muita atenção dele eu aproveitei
contra aquele que dizem todos os meses a
gente tem uma reunião com todos os
funcionários da empresa em que os
novatos têm lá na frente se apresentar e
contar algo que não está no perfil do
linkedin deles que é uma maneira
parecida de descobrir as habilidade e já
na fila do táxi nos despedindo então ele
me perguntou e me dizem o que é que não
está no seu perfil do linkedin
eu fiquei um pouco sem graça não saber
muito que falar e acabei contando sobre
um hobby 9 que eu tinha na época e disse
que era dj
o que não podia imaginar é que ele ia
virar super empolgado e dizer mentira eu
também sou dj e foi nesse dia no caminho
de volta para casa
eu comecei a pensar sobre o profissional
do futuro na verdade mas ainda sobre eu
como uma profissional do futuro não é
novidade pra ninguém que a tecnologia
está mudando o mundo e nos levando para
um futuro ainda desconhecido
nos próximos anos a inteligência
artificial exclui centenas de milhares
de pessoas do mercado de trabalho e esse
é um problema em escala global que vai
afetar a economia de todos os países e
se por um lado já existe um movimento
para esse assunto me assusta ver que a
maioria das pessoas não fazem idéia
sequer do tamanho dessa ruptura
tecnológica que está a acontecer e eu
estou falando de algo que vai acontecer
daqui a 200 anos
é uma mudança que já começou e vai se
intensificar demais nos próximos 10 ou
20 anos
a substituição de emprego por robôs e
softwares tem sido tema de diversos
estudos e um deles da universidade jogos
só aponta que aproximadamente 47% dos
empregos tendem a desaparecer nos
próximos 20 anos
e aqui não estou falando só de
motoristas operadores de telemarketing e
corretores
professores médicos e advogados também
estão nessa lista
atualmente um site chamado web de uma
coleção de sites de saúde é em que as
pessoas podem fazer consultas online
recebe mais visitas do que todos os
médicos nos estados unidos
já no mundo das disputas judiciais todos
os anos mais de 60 milhões de desacordos
entre comerciantes do ebay são
resolvidos através de resolução de
disputas online ou seja robôs
ao invés de advogados e juízes
e se a gente pensa que só nós
profissionais vão ser transformados em
robôs
o vaticano concedeu a primeira licença
digital aplicativo chamado confissão que
vai ajudar as pessoas a se prepararem
para se confessar e eu fico imaginando
como será que vai ser se confessar para
um robô padre pois é
se de um lado a gente tem 6 milhões de
empregos desaparecendo
é claro que diante dessa nova economia
muitos novos empregos vão surgir mas
existe um ponto importante aqui a gente
olha para a trajetória da revolução
industrial quando os humanos foram
substituídas pelas máquinas
isso geralmente acontece em trabalhos de
baixa qualificação
quando a gente não precisava mais os
trabalhadores agrícolas que representava
80% do mercado de trabalho na época eles
passaram a ocupar as vagas nas
indústrias que estavam sujeito ou seja
eles deixaram de arar a terra e passar a
apertar parafusos nas linhas de montagem
quando esses empregos as linhas de
montagem começaram a ser automatizados
também eles passaram da linha de
montagem para serviços de baixa
qualificação que é onde essas pessoas
estão
chin ou seja até que a gente sempre de
um jeito né
agora quando as pessoas dizem que haverá
novos empregos do futuro e que os
humanos podem ser melhores do que a
inteligência artificial e que os humanos
podem ser melhores do que os robôs essas
pessoas geralmente pensa em trabalho de
alta qualificação com pessoas que vão
trabalhar com robótica com gratificação
com realidade aumentada
eu não vejo como motorista de caminhão
desempregado aos 50 anos que perdeu seu
emprego para veículos autônomos nem como
um caixa de supermercado que não teve
oportunidade de estudo vai se reinventar
diante desses empregos do futuro que vão
exigir uma alta qualificação e isso faz
com que o mundo caminha para uma
desigualdade jamais vista antes
uma vez que os mais afetados serão essas
pessoas de baixa qualificação e de baixa
renda
e aí o que a gente faz com tanta gente
que vai ficar sem emprego
muita gente que as diz que a solução
para isso é a possibilidade de se criar
uma renda básica universal ou seja
oferecer uma renda básica para qualquer
adulto independente dessa pessoa
trabalhar ou não eu confesso que fiquei
um pouco chocada a primeira vez que ouvi
falar nesse assunto mas ele vem ganhando
cada vez mais novos adeptos inclusive
grandes nomes do vale do silício com o
mark zuckerberg ela marca a iniciativa
vista como uma forma de compensar o
desemprego gerado pela automação
só que aqui não está claro que a
universal nem o que é básico
quando a gente fala renda básica
universal
a gente pensa na verdade um problema de
forma nacional
o problema é global e vou dar um exemplo
aqui pra gente entender melhor isso
imaginem vocês que a inteligência
artificial as impressoras 3d vão incluir
milhões de trabalhadores escravos em
bangladesh
quem vai pagar a renda básica deles
em troca os estados unidos e europa vão
recolher imposto do google da amazon da
época e vão usar esse dinheiro para
pagar a renda básica dos bengaleses
eu não sei o que vocês acham disso mas
eu particularmente não acho que isso vá
acontecer
e aqui também não está claro o que é
básico quando a gente fala e renda
básica universal o que é básico pra
vocês
quais são as necessidades básicas do ser
humano
algumas pessoas vão dizer que alimento e
abrigo são suficientes
já outras vão dizer a educação tem que
fazer parte desse pacote mas a gente
fala de educação de quanto tempo a gente
está falando
seis anos 12 anos em hd
[Música]
quando as pessoas perdem a sua
empregabilidade
a única coisa que vale ressaltar é a
renda básica universal então que compõem
essa cesta é uma questão ética muito
delicada
a gente está falando do provável o
surgimento de uma enorme classe de
pessoas ociosas e aí eu fico pensando
será que essas pessoas que reclamam
tanto do trabalho vão ficar felizes com
essa possibilidade
ou será que doenças como estresse
depressão obesidade e até suicídio vão
se agravar ainda mais diante dessa falta
do que fazer então como a gente se
prepara para esse mundo que a gente nem
sabe ainda bem qual vai ser
afinal quais são os empregos do futuro
detetive de dados
psicólogo de robôs é verdade que não tem
essa resposta não sei dizer quais são os
empregos do futuro eu acho que talvez
ninguém ainda tenha essa resposta mas do
jeito que 10 12 anos atrás a gente não
sabia que iam assistir no youtube ers
motoristas de hubert desenvolvedora do
aplicativo jogadores de liga fred antes
a gente também não tem como dizer quais
serão os empregos do futuro 65% das
crianças que estão no ensino médio hoje
vão trabalhar em um emprego que ainda
não existe mas então como que essas
escolas essas universidades se preparam
diante de um futuro tão incerto
eu já estive algumas vezes no vale do
silício visitando as universidades mais
inovadoras de lá você tem universidades
em campos universidade sem professores
do colégio para crianças superdotadas
que aprendem através de projetos com
impressoras 3d corte a laser foi uma
universidade do google com a nasa que
fica dentro da nasa teve muita coisa
muito legal muito interessante mas uma
das que mais me chamou a atenção foi uma
escola chamada minerva school em que há
além de bairros coisas super legais que
eles têm
eles têm um foco muito grande em
desenvolver as habilidades
comportamentais de seus alunos
foi uma das primeiras vezes na vida que
ouvi dizer que as habilidades do futuro
não serão as habilidades técnicas e sim
as habilidades comportamentais uma vez
que com a inteligência artificial
os robôs poderiam aprender quase
qualquer habilidade técnica que a gente
tem hoje mais ou menos não tão cedo
poderia desenvolver suas habilidades
comportamentais hoje economic fórum
reforçou esse insight quando estou e
apresentou ali quais serão as 10
habilidades mais importante para o
profissional do futuro e confirmou que
todas elas sem exceção serão habilidades
comportamentais e não técnicas
em outras palavras pra ser bem sucedido
nesse profissional do futuro vai ter que
saber como pensar e não mais o que
pensar
a maioria das escolas e das
universidades hoje nos ensinam o que
pensar e não como pensar a gente cresceu
ouvindo dos nossos pais dos nossos
professores dos nossos chefes da
sociedade em geral o que era certo eo
que é errado e deixou o modelo linear
industrial como aquele que a gente
fizesse o que era certo a gente tinha
uma chance muito grande de sermos bem
sucedidos já na era digital decorar
nomes de forma já não faz mais sentido
as respostas estão prontas na internet
isso não quer dizer que a gente não vai
ter que se desenvolver tecnicamente a
gente vai sentar e desenvolver suas
habilidades ea chance de elas estarem
ligadas
tecnologia qualificação é enorme porém
ea velocidade da mudança das coisas vai
ser tão grande que essas habilidades
técnicas vão ter um prazo de validade
muito curto
em outras palavras esse profissional do
futuro então vai ter que ser um longa
life lanã ou seja ele vai ter que
aprender pra sempre aquela história de
que a gente vai estudar até aos 20 e
poucos anos ea gente vai entrar no
mercado de trabalho ea gente vai fazer
algumas pequenas pausas para 1 mb para
uma pós graduação
não vamos fazer nenhum sentido diante
dessa nova economia
dizem inclusive que esse profissional do
futuro vai ter aproximadamente até cinco
carreiras ao longo da vida
isso se ela não contou aconteceram ao
mesmo tempo futuro estava em off ler
disse que o analfabeto do século 21 não
será aquele que não sabe ler e escrever
sim aquele que não souber aprender a
desaprender e reaprender é claro que
isso tudo são possibilidades mas o que
eu sinto é que independente do que vai
acontecer no futuro nós humanos hoje
estamos ficando cada vez melhores em
compreender o cérebro ea inteligência
mas a gente está evoluindo cada vez
menos a nossa consciência e as pessoas
confundem inteligência e consciência e
inteligência capacidade de resolver
problemas e consciência capacidade de
sentir a gente está criando inteligência
artificial mas a gente não tá criando
consciência artificial
dizem que no ano de 2029 o computador
vai se tornar tão inteligente quanto nós
seres humanos e que em 2045 um único
computador vai ser mais inteligente do
que toda a humanidade junta
porém não há nenhum indício de que
esconde que estes computadores vão se
tornar conscientes ao menos tão certo
eles não vão poder sentir esse é isso
que vai diferenciar a gente dos
computadores é isso que vai diferenciar
gente dos robôs
a gente tem que começar a desenvolver
mais a consciência humana
a gente tá cada vez mais desenvolvendo
nosso externo esquecendo de olhar pra
dentro da gente
cada vez mais nos é cobrado que a gente
seja melhor profissional o mais bem
sucedido o mais inteligente mais
competitivo mas ninguém ensina a gente a
lidar com as nossas emoções
a gente não aprender e não entender que
a felicidade não está em ter se em ser a
gente vai continuar criando mais e mais
robôs humanas pois não é preciso ser um
robô para agir comum
então hoje quando eu penso quem será o
profissional do futuro quem serei eu
como profissional do futuro
pra mim o profissional do futuro vai sim
desenvolver as habilidades externas mas
ele não desenvolveu pesquisas internas e
conseguiu equilibrar esse dentro dele a
chance de viver uma vida medíocre
infeliz era muito grande
em outras palavras o ser humano do
profissional do futuro nada mais é do
que um ser humano do futuro
e hoje quando me perguntam o que é que
não está no meu perfil do linkedin
eu digo que além de ser dj e vem
acordando de anos em que eu vivi
anestesiada
eu levei anos para perceber que eu era
uma perfeita ninguém que eu respondi à
demanda da sociedade às demandas do meu
trabalho às demandas da minha família
- as minhas até porque eu não tinha a
menor idéia de quais eram as minhas
próprias vontades se não atender às
expectativas dos outros e hoje quando me
perguntam o que é que me fez acordar de
tudo isso foi o amor o amor em perceber
e descobrir e aceitar a beleza das
minhas próprias imperfeições e vocês
o que é que não está no seu perfil do
linkedin
[Música]
obrigada